on m j'adore c'est vraiment un bon
souvenir de mon enfance
on a des peanuts après cordes a sauvé
des pirates sassignol jet pack avant ça
on est pas les six signataires site est
vraiment bon mon père est blessé mais
vraiment lui voulait toujours la famille
au final non des deux bobos dans les 90
on aimait sans doute
j'essaie à chaque année prospère qu'est
ce qui devrait pourtant c'est pas la
saveur de la gomme ce qu'est ce qu'il ya
à l'intérieur des petites vioxx puis je
pense pas qu'il y avait salle en étoile
au mans je sens que c'était un des
premiers qui ça n'allait pas ce qu'on
voulait tout avoir les histoires parce
que cela c'est dur ça c'est un trésor un
petit peu savaient pas comme du siècle
je pense pas une secte mais on fait ça
ressemble à des nous paraît qu'il fait
mais tous dans ce temps leur et puis on
avait tellement pc avec sort mais
croyez-moi c'est je suis contente de
savoir qu'il n'y a plus de petit fils au
bout de toutes sources sas marge pour je
me souviens qu'à qu'on est à petit on
amasse allaient de porte en porte
quelques nouvelles à propos de monsieur
lamarre en sûrs matin une quinzaine de
boxe était la meilleure chose recevoir
on adore elle est propre
tu t'es déjà reçu ce matin sac durement
quelque chose qu'on a pour moi c'est
comme même que ce pacte a taquiné
matheson l'osce a écrasé toute notre
équipe donc on s'assurer d'avoir un sac
à dos avec nous promettent l'époque dans
notre sac à dos pour essayer d'éviter de
écraser tous nos sacs de tubes qu'on va
sauver des belles pam onu un carton et
capecchi qui tendrait sport oui on était
bons mois que l'eau s'en fallait que
cache ce n'était pas d'un coup bien que
boyd ses rangs en tout cas laisse moi
vous dire ça c'était la crête plus
saisir ya beaucoup nous indiquant que
bonnie fera sa laporte lavallois n'a pas
tellement de beaux souvenirs d'avant et
puis à ça c'est en est vraiment une